Great Grandma, what was it like long ago?
What was it like when you were young like me?
Great Grandma, did you watch TV long ago?
Did you watch TV when you were young like me?
No, dear Adam, we did not have TV.
I listened to the radio when I was young like you.
Great Grandma, did you fly in an airplane long ago?
Did you fly in an airplane when you were young like me?
No, dear Adam, we did not fly in airplanes.
I rode on a train when I was young like you.
Great Grandma, did you play video games long ago?
Did you play video games when you were young like me?
No, dear Adam, we did not have video games.
I played board games when I was young like you.
Great Grandma, did you have plastic toys long ago?
Did you have plastic toys when you were young like me?
No, dear Adam, we did not have plastic toys.
I played with wooden toys when I was young like you.
Great Grandma, were you happy when you were young like me?
Yes, Adam, I was happy when I was young like you.
I had a grandma who loved me just like I love you.